هذه هي المره الاولى منذ 12 سنه التي يتم
فيها الحديث عن سنسرت عمل الدرامي في تونس
والى الان تلتزم مؤسسه التلفزه التونسيه
الصمت ازاء هذه الاتهامات خلينا نخفف شويه
احتدام احلام ونروح على حرب من نوع مختلفه
في تونس حرب الموز عم تشتد بين الرقابه
والمحتكرين هناك من يشتري الموز خلصت ما
القصه
[موسيقى]
بالفعل هي في الحقيقه الحرب محتجمه وهي
حرب في الحقيقه حرب فرض الدوله وفرض هيبه
الدوله والقانون لكن فاحيانا تكتسي هذه
الحرب نوعا من الطرافه اذ وبعد ان شددت
الدوله من الرقابه على المحتكرين
والمضاربين التجا هؤلاء الى طرق جهنميه من
اجل مغالطه السلطات وكذلك لكن السلطات
تفتنت بالطبع وهذا ما تم الاعلان عنه
رسميا فقام المحتكر الموز وموزعوه
بتوزيعه خلسه واثناء الليل يعني ليس في
الاوقات العاديه للتبذى بل اثناء الليل في
اماكن ربما معينه يذهب المواطنون ويقتنون
الموزه خلصتا تحت جنح الظلام لكن الوزاره
كشفت هذا وكانت بينت في ندوه صحفيه انه تم
ايضا القاء القبض على مجموعه ممن توخوا
هذه الحيله
ولا جبل الاحمر يا
طبعا هي اسعى في الحقيقه هذه حرب الموز
التي كانت سمه رمضان هذه السنه بامتياز
لان المواطنين يقبلون على استهلاك الموز
في رمضان الذي هو ماده مستورده بالكامل
وسعارته الدوله بسعر معين لكن بعض
المحتكرين يرفضون هذا السعر والتجاوا الى
الخلسه والى الظلام والليل لكن لم يسعفهم
الحظ وتم القاء القبض عليهم شكرا احلام
العبد الله من تونس
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات